بالفعل لم يصدر اي بيان رسمي ولم تتبنى
اسرائيل الرسميه عمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري في الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت
وهذا ربما يعزى الى يعني مسارين مختلفين
الاول ان فعلا اسرائيل لا تعلن عن عمليات
الاغتيال التي تقوم بها عاده وهناك عمليات
اغتيال نسبت الى اسرائيل وعمرها اكثر من
10 عاما ولم تعلن عنها حتى هذا اليوم
الثاني لا يمكن فصله عن سياق الخلافات
الداخليه الاسرائيليه وخاصه مجلس الحرب
قبل عده اسابيع وعندما قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي خلال مؤتمر صحفي انه ان كافه
قيادات حركه حماس تحت طائله الملاحقه
الاسرائيليه في الخارج تدخل نتنياهو في
نفس الوقت وقال نعم انا الذي اعطيت الامر
للاجهزه الامنيه بتعقب قيادات حركه حماس
كان واضحا ان هناك خلاف وكان واضحا ان
هناك سباق لدى القيادات الاسرائيليه وخاصه
قيادات مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي على من
سيحرز نقطه في هذا في في حلبه الصراع
بينهم فيما يتعلق في التغلب على حركه حماس
ومساعي التغلب على الحركه خلال هذه الحرب
التي يعني يقول كثير من المحللين
الاسرائيليين ان اسرائيل لم تحقق فيها حتى
الان انجازا عسكريا واضحا وكبيرا ولم
تستطع تحقيق الكثير من بنود واهداف هذه
الحرب التي وضعتها وهي اعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين من قطاع غزه وقتل كافه
قيادات حماس وكذلك كتفكيك هذه الحركه اذا
هذا ايضا سياق يمكن وضع هذا ال هذه هذا
التعتيم الاسرائيلي في داخله ايضا ربما
بحاجه الى بعض الوقت لكي تعلن اسرائيل حتى
يتفق القاده في اسرائيل من سيعلن هذا هذه
العمليه ربما ايضا نعم في الحقيقه نتنياهو
امر جميع الوزراء بعدم الحديث عن هذه
العمليه وذلك بعد ان بادر عدد من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين الى فعلا الحديث
والاشاده بعمليه اغتيال صالح العاروري
تدخل حزب اللكود الحاكم وكذلك ديوان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وامر
كافه المسؤولين والوزراء فعليا بعدم
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع لا حديث اسرائيلي
رسمي عن هذه عن هذا الموضوع ابدا ولكن
هناك اشارات في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ولكن هذه الاشارات منقوله عن
تصريحات اجنبيه وفي بعض الاحيان تصريحات
امريكيه او وسائل اعلام امريكيه وهي يعني
لغه مع اعتمد في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وت تعتمدها الرقابه
الاسرائيليه عاده للافصاح عن معلومات ربما
او الحديث عن عمليات بهذا الحجم مثل عمليه
اغتيال صالح العاروري المشهد في اسرائيل
مركب المشهد في اسرائيل هو يسوده الهدوء
الحذر قبل قليل تحدثت وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه عن تقديرات بان حزب الله قد يرد
بشكل موسع جدا على هذه العمليه موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي اشار الى ان حزب الله قد
يستهدف منطقه المركز في اسرائيل هنا مثلا
على سبيل المثال مدينه تل ابيب وكذلك يمكن
كما يشير الموقع نقلا عن مصادر وتقديرات
ان ينفذ حزب الله اللبناني عمليات تستهدف
اسرائيليين خارج اسرائيل وهذا ما يرفع
حاله التوتر داخل اسرائيل والمستوى الامني
والعسكري والسياسي عقدوا اليوم اجتماعات
كثيره واستمرت وقتا طويلا لبحث التصعيد
المحتمل في شمال اسرائيل من قبل حزب الله
اللبناني هذه الجبهه التي من المتوقع كما
ترى مصادر اسرائيليه ان تشتعل في اعقاب
هذه العمليه وربما هذا سبب اضافي ايضا
يدفع اسرائيل الى عدم تبني هذه العمليه
رسميا رغم ان حزب الله وحماس وغيرها قد
نسبوا هذه العمليه لاسرائيل بشكل واضح